[Musique]
il faut savoir que facebook point de vue
des chiffres c'est 2 milliards
d'utilisateurs par jour c'est 350
millions de photos postées chaque jour
et ses 8 milliard de vues sur les vidéos
par jour
on ne peut pas mettre un modérateur
humain derrière chaque utilisateur c'est
impossible c'est humainement impossible
c'est pour ça tu as les réseaux et les
plateformes comme facebook ou twitter
met en place des algorithmes des bottes
qui vont analyser le contenu qui sera
posté pour ensuite déterminer si c'est
une fête news6 talent est conforme à un
consensus scientifique
on sait que facebook et twitter se sont
déjà positionnés sur l'efficacité des
vaccins
s'il n'y a pas un algorithme pour venir
faire le ménage
il ya des chances pour qu'on se retrouve
avec avec des populations entières qui
refuseront de se faire vacciner
et dans ce cas là le coronavirus sera le
cadet de nos soucis
il faut pas oublier enfin en tout cas
moi c'est mon c'est mon sentiment
aujourd'hui que on a une certaine
duplicité je pèse mes mots
ambivalence en tout cas de de facebook
par rapport à la modération parce que
son intérêt à facebook c'est d'avoir le
maximum de milliards de deux par jour
oui le maximum d'utilisateurs qui
fonctionne et de quoi vit facebook et
quel est son sont aujourd'hui son moteur
comment ça se nourrit et masser les
données personnelles
or plus il ya des données personnelles
plus facebook fonctionne
ces données personnelles elle valait
collecter justement lorsqu'il ya des
contenus qui sont partagés les contenus
qui sont partagés sont souvent
malheureusement les contenus qui sont
qu'ils sont erronés ou faux un mensonge
va plus de six fois plus vite que la
vérité sur les sur les réseaux sociaux
et donc on comprend très bien donc les
les lits problématique qui peut y avoir
par rapport par rapport à cela donc
est-ce qu'on va couper court avec un à
gori extrêmement extrêmement puissant
est extrêmement solide pour couper court
à tout est tué dans l'oeuf
en fait tout chèque news de coûts
couper court à tout le groupe de
discussion qui pourrait amener ce type
de comportement sur sur les réseaux
sociaux où est ce qu'on va laisser quand
même planer une embellie dont on va
enfermer certains et pas d'autres
et il essaie quand même les choses se
passent et on n'est plus dans des débats
d'opinion
c'est sur facebook comme sur twitter
on est plus sur des débats d'opinion
parce que c'est le coeur du problème
beaucoup trop de gens font passer des
opinions pour des faits et on ne se
dirige pas vers la pensée unique où on
se dirige tout droit vers de la
désinformation et je crois que ces
luttes et c'est ça le père du problème
c'est pas le fait de supprimer du
contenu qui va nous diriger vers un
verre une pensée unique parce que au
final une réalité il y en a qu'une
l'efficacité des vaccins n'est même plus
à démontrer et ça c'est pas une pensée
unique que de dire que les vaccins sont
peut-être la meilleure chose qui fut
inventé d'un point de vue médical depuis
ces dernières décennies
c'est pas une pensée unique de dire ça
donc non moi je suis convaincu qu'on ne
part pas vers vers une pensée unique
parce que des gens parce qu'on veut
supprimer du contenu de personnes qui
font passer des faits qui font passer
des opinions pour des faits non enfin ce
n'est pas du tout ma mamma vision et je
ne crains pas ce genre de dérives je
pense que les libertés d'expression dodo
doit demeurer la règle c'est c'est à
c'est un élément fondamental de
démocratie de nos deux au système il
faut absolument qu'elle qu'elle perdure
et qu'elle puisse croître et prospérer
donc ce qui est totalement indispensable
aujourd'hui sur les réseaux sociaux me
semble-t-il c'est que justement cette
modération et ses algorithmes permettent
de d'éclater un petit peu des contacts
vous pouvez avoir le contenu que vous
pouvez voir passer ça aussi de d'imposer
en fait des contenus à des personnes
parce que ces supposés être ceux qui qui
vont vous intéresser et ceux qui sont
dans les dents
vous que vos amis vos ennemis ont donc
et entretenir comme ça un espèce d'entre
eux soit pour élargir justement céder
des vaccins
voilà que dans une bulle d'anti vaccin
mais il puisse y avoir des informations
par rapport à la réalité sur sur les
informations scientifiques concernant
concernant les vaccinations
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ce qui me choque c'est
l'absence de recours vous pouvez avoir
tout un chacun fils qui fait le mot vous
dit votre compte est supprimée ou être
content et fier pendu vous n'avez
strictement aucun recours
donc il ça c'est totalement impossible
tant d'une dans une démocratie et je
pense qu'il faut impérativement que le
juge se retrouve sa place
alors avec le parquet numérique on nous
met en place en france en tout cas qu'on
lui mette les moyens qu'on mette des
modérateurs judiciaire on va presque
dire qu'ils pourraient être intervenir
de manière beaucoup plus rapide sur sur
des contenus qui pourraient sont les
problématiques sur des preuves sur
justement cette île de ce type de de
contenu ça me semble ça me semble
indispensable si la justice doit
intervenir sur le contenu ce sera
d'abord sur les sur les menaces de mort
sur le contenu à caractère haineux
terroriste pédopornographie je pense que
déjà rien que ça ça va les occuper pas
mal
il s'avère qu'en france nous avons des
joies déjà des lois qui interdisent la
diffusion de fausses nouvelles
ce sont des lois punissent qui sont
considérés comme des infractions pénales
alors certes mon interlocuteur parler et
en partie raison je pense sociale jugent
injuste de déterminer si si si un
contenu est en infraction avec la loi
je suis bien d'accord mais où est le mal
pour une plateforme de déjà faire le tri
si les gens auront envie de parler de
leurs théories qu'ils écrivent des
romans qu'ils fassent des films de
science-fiction outils ce monde des
blogs facebook c'est une boîte privée
ils ont un règlement on le sait tous
sont les atouts on l'a tous accepté ce
règlement donc si on ne respecte pas je
ne vois pas où est le problème à ce que
l'on soit sanctionner entre guillemets
[Musique]